تتعافى الآن واحدة من أول الناجين الأمريكيين المعروفين من
كوفين 19 الذين
تلقوا عملية زرع رئة مزدوجة
وتتحدث
عن التجربة التي
تلقت ميرا راميريز البالغة من العمر 28 عامًا
عملية زرع الرئة
في الطب الشمالي الغربي في شيكاغو الآن
بعد أسابيع من العناية المركزة وهي
تحقق
تقدمًا ممتازًا أولاً  ميرا ، اسمح لي أن
أبدأ معك ، نحن سعداء جدًا بمعرفة
أنك تتعافى ،
وأتفهم أنك مرضت في أبريل / نيسان ،
وحصلت على عملية الزرع في يونيو
، وأخيراً عدت إلى المنزل ، لا يمكنني
إلا أن أتخيل ما
كانت هذه الرحلة المجنونة والمخيفة  من أجلك ، هل
يمكنك إخبارنا عن معركتك
مع الفيروس ، ما الذي حدث
وكيف كانت عملية التعافي لديك ،
حسنًا ، لقد
كنت أعمل أولاً من المنزل ، ولم أكن
أذهب إلى أي مكان
كنت أتخذ احتياطاته ، ولم أكن
حتى أسير  كلبي
في 26 أبريل / نيسان ، ذهبت إلى غرفة الطوارئ ،
كل شيء حدث بسرعة كبيرة ، حيث أخذوا
عناصري الحيوية ، كان حوض الأكسجين الخاص بي منخفضًا جدًا
، وكانوا يسارعون إلى
تغييره في غضون 10 دقائق.  كان
لدي دقيقتين
للاتصال بأسرتي لإخبارهم أنه كان من المقرر أن يتم
تنبيبي ،
لقد طُلب مني تعيين شخص
ما كشخص معين
لاتخاذ القرارات الطبية نيابة عني ، لذلك
قمت بتعيين
والدتي وأختي الكبرى بعد ذلك
كل ما أتذكره هو أنني كنت أنام
أثناء تنبيبي ثم ستة
أسابيع من الكوابيس الكاملة ،
فمن الصعب تمييز ما كان
واقعًا
وما حدث بالفعل ،
بعض الكوابيس كانت عبارة عن
غرق شديد وأنا أعزو ذلك إلى
عدم القدرة  لأتنفس وتكافح من أجل التنفس
خلال ذلك الوقت ، هل تعلم أنني
في الإسبانية تعني كلمة جهاز التنفس الصناعي
مثل جهاز التنفس الصناعي مثل المروحة ،
لم أكن أدرك خطورة
الموقف
بالنسبة لي ، فالمعجب يعني فقط أنهم
سيعلمون المساعدة  أتنفس ، أعطني
بعض
الهواء وسأكون على ما يرام ، لذلك كنت
أتوقع
ربما على الأكثر إقامة لمدة ثلاثة أيام
وليس ستة أسابيع في هذا الحدث حيث
انتهى بي الأمر إلى أن
أكون موجودًا وعائلتي كانت كود أم
أنهم يعيشون جميعًا في الشمال  كارولينا أنا أفعل ،
كنت مع
صديقي في ذلك الوقت ، إنه الشخص
الذي أوصلني إلى
غرفة الطوارئ وكان هناك كل يوم ،
وأنت تعلم
أن تسجّل وصولي ولكن بخلاف ذلك ، كانت عائلتي
في حالة جهل بشأن كل شيء
كانوا يتلقون مكالمات هاتفية
يوميًا ليروا كيف كنت أفعل ، ثم
قيل لهم ذات يوم
إنني لن أتجاوز
الليل وأنت تعلم
ما إذا كانوا
يريدون الطيران لأعلى ليقولوا وداعًا أم لا  لأنه
قبل ذلك بسبب التعامل مع
قيود 19 ، لم يكن المستشفى
يسمح
لأفراد الأسرة ، لذلك لم أكن أو أي شخص على
الإطلاق ،
لذلك لم أتمكن من احتجازهم أو رؤيتهم أو
لم يكونوا قادرين على أن يكونوا
كذلك.  في تلك الليلة ، هل تعلم أن عائلتي
أخذت أول رحلة طيران
من كلينتون شمال كارولينا
حيث أنا أيضًا
ولكنهم أخذوا أول رحلة من
شمال كارولينا
ليأتوا لرؤيتي ، لذا بحلول الوقت الذي
وصلوا فيه إلى هنا  كانوا يشرحون
خيار زرع الرئة
لأن رئتي هي نفسها  هل تعلم أن
أممم تالفة بشكل لا رجعة فيه وأنه
خيار أخير بالنسبة لي ، لم يكن هناك
أي شيء آخر يمكنهم القيام به ،
حيث بدأت أعضائي الأخرى في الفشل
أيضًا
نتيجة لفشل رئتي
وأذهلني بعد 48 ساعة ،
تلقيت  زرع الرئة في الخامس من حزيران (يونيو)
لم يكن لدي أدنى فكرة أنني تلقيت
عملية زرع رئة ، لكنني أعلم فقط أنني كنت
في المستشفى ،
نظرت إلى نفسي ، ولم أستطع التعرف
على جسدي ،
ولم أستطع التحدث ، وبالكاد يمكنني رفع إصبع لم أستطع
لم أتحرك كنت أشعر بألم
شديد كنت مرتبكًا جدًا كنت عطشانًا جدًا ،
كل ما كنت أفكر فيه هو أنني
كنت أريدها لم أستطع
معالجة ذهني لم يكن لدي
القدرة على القيام بذلك على ما أعتقد بسبب
التخدير  لقد
فقدت الكثير من القدرات المعرفية
بالإضافة إلى القدرة
الجسدية ، ومع ذلك لا يمكنك سماع ذلك
ورؤيتك الآن والطريقة التي
توضح بها
ما حدث بالضبط ، فأنت
ترسم هذه الصورة الحية ،
إنه أمر لا يصدق  انظر إلى مدى قوتك
وكيف تبدو اليوم بالنظر إلى مدى مرضك
كنت